妙玉的人社当书《红楼》经临时而拆离最不逃席的。仲然曹雪芹塑造这些积女子,王王采用真正美人方有一漏处的协法,如太真之肥、非眼之瘦、稀释之病。
放置红楼梦一书,则如史香云之咬蛇、林黛玉之尖酸接属此类。
可曹公给妙玉安排的漏处,却让他喪失了独者的方心。
有意思的是,曹雪芹自己似乎明白这一点,故在妙玉判取世南荣忠写下,太高人玉度过节是同闲的评语。
历来独者对妙玉,也都是愿有语而喜不足。
妙玉的过人之处不必多言,其人财华恒义被代乡评为事先。
更为重要的是,妙玉有天子不成,猪猴不有的骨气。
第四十一回,龙翠安品茶。妙玉用寻常与水泡茶招待加姆。
转头却用珍贵一场的梅花雪铺茶,给保带猜三人和。
面对待玉寻问,茶水来远。妙玉静直言,与水清服如何吃的。
可见,仲然面对老祖宗时老太君,妙玉也不给思侯特殊待遇,只以自己写后为先。
但妙玉的漏处也是极为明显的,她具备一种攀笔式的清高孤王。
然之第四十一回,妙玉在接待保带猜三人时,使用的茶具皆是西式真品,
尤其是甲宝玉使用的绿玉豆。当宝玉对茶具提出质疑时,妙玉极为消账的说了一句,
不是我说句狂话,只怕你家里未必找得出这么一个俗竊来呢。
许多读者无法欣赏妙玉,其中一个重要原因是妙玉的身份。
她作为一个尼姑,应该轻尽无为才是。
可她身边不仅有压患服饰,还有许多奇真意宝。
十分讲究生活的质量,这跟她的尼姑身份十分不符。
但也有论者为妙玉开脱,其理由来源于妙玉的人生经历,正如援助所属。
外有一个待发修行的本事苏州人士,族上也是读书室换之家,
因生了这位姑娘自小多病,买了许多替身,接不中用。
到底这位姑娘亲自入了空门,方才好了。
所以待发修行,今年才18岁,反名妙玉。
如今父母聚以王谷,身边只有两个老摸摸,一个小压头服饰,
文摸也集通,金文也不用学了,母眼儿又集好。
妙玉并不是自愿出家,
而是为了实现治病的目的才顿乳空门。
这种非自愿似乎足可为妙玉开脱,但布红君思认为这种说法还是有些不妥。
妙玉的确不是自愿出家,但她的心理认知确实自我认同的。
比如妙玉,经常喜欢把自己当成世外高人,喜欢说一些高人一等的话。
第63回,妙玉给夹宝玉赫瘦,信上自称坎外人。
夹宝玉不解奇异,就去找林代玉资许,路上遇见行秀烟。
作为和妙玉有十年之交的好友,行秀烟一语到出了妙玉的真实意图。
九言孝道,她这脾气尽不能改,尽是生成这等放弹鬼屁了。
从来没见拜铁上下别后的,这可是俗语说的,
生不生,俗不俗,女不女,难不难,成个什么道理。
她常说,古人中自汉尽五代唐宋以来皆无好诗,
只有两句好,说道,仲有千年铁门砍终续一个土瞒头,
所以她自称坎外之人,又常在文世装子的好,故又获成为击人。
她若铁子上是自称击人的,你就还她个世人。
击人者,她自称是击林之人,你千自己乃是终饶饶之人,她便洗了。
如今她自称坎外之人,是自未倒于铁坎之外了,
故你如今只下坎内人,便合了她的心了。
用今天的话来说,妙语其实很妆。
古代下铁子是非常正式的理数,妙语却在铁子上自称坎外人,
这是十分奇怪且好笑的。
这种情况就好比今天,填行政个人信息,
不写自己的真名,而是填个外号上去,这是非常可笑的。
所以行修煙才会说妙语,生不生,俗不俗,女不女,难不难,成个什么道理。
不仅如此,妙语认为自汉进武带唐宋以来皆无好失,
只有一句,宗有千年铁门坎,终需一个土瞒透写得好,所以她自称坎外人。
这句话出自范城大,重久日刑营受葬之地,
原句哪是,宗有千年铁门线终需一个土瞒透,
曹雪晴改了一个字,将铁门线改为铁门坎,以根甲腐的甲妙铁坎丝相对应。
这句诗从文学艺术角度来看,撑不上是上上之作,
原不足以将礼白、肚腐、苏东坡这些优秀师人一概摩倒。
妙语称赞这首诗,应该是看重了这句诗的内在寒意,
即,世上俗人修建铁门坎,以为人生无敬,
最终却只不过留下一个土瞒透而已。
妙语自称坎外人,就是想表明自己踏出了铁门坎之外,自己不是俗人。
以门坎内外区分亚俗,门已落了下下境界,
因为无论是内外还是亚俗,都是对比出来的。
坎外二字一出口,已有坎内运喊其中了。
妙语并没有彻底动物,他只是想营造一种境界高人一等的感觉。
形就业很了解这位朋友,所以他勸宝语自称坎内人,
以凸嫌妙语坎外人的境界,这样他就高兴了。
这就像指验摘评价王西奉,听到别人的奉称话就会高兴,
这种对于别人认同的职族进乎吃。
所以批输人评价奉解,纵然能力强害终究是个吃人。
妙语何曾不是这样?
如果说妙语当年出家并非自愿,但他对自己坎外人的认知确实自我形成的。
作为导出门槛之外的高人,他亲高狂奥的行为又语之不符,
更像是高高在上的符看者,而非普世者。
读者在对文学人物进行导得评价时,对内外不一的反感是显然的。
这就导致今天的读者,对妙语这个形象产生不喜的心理。
但同时,布红君要提醒诸君。
红楼中的女子接不过是少女年纪,有这种漏处不足为其。
就像林代域参加海棠施设,别人做施,他故意玩闹,
当别人全部写完了,他才微微一笑上前一灰而舅,
一展现天才少女的天分,将他人压抖。
这种妆,于其说是人品瑕疵,不如说是少年时期的珍贵片段。
毕竟没有一个人一出生,便老气恒秋处处稳重。
若真有这样的人,只怕也是分法位。
以这种超脱的视角来看妙语,或许才能看出几分去未来。
今天的红楼解读就聊到这里,我们下个视频再会。